next question today is from lady lady
says David you seem really skeptical in
general can you tell me which of the
following you believe in if none can
these all really be fake psychic
abilities ESP Reiki acupuncture
astrology telekinesis ghosts the sole
lucky and unlucky numbers any ability to
communicate with the dead numerology and
tarot card reading okay so I don't want
to come off like I just don't believe
anything but you've listed all stuff
which is mostly bogus in some way shape
or form so let me go through a few of
these okay psychic abilities I'm open to
being possible I've not seen a Vee any
evidence that there is such a thing as
psychic ability so far ESP is sort of
similar ESP stands for extrasensory
perception which I think psychic
abilities are sort of a kind of ESP but
I know ESP can encompass other things
I'm open to the idea that science will
someday explain to us how and why
so-called ESP or psychic abilities work
so far what I've seen is people that are
very skilled at what's called cold
reading or are running scams right where
they're being fed information about
people in an earpiece James Randi has
exposed a lot of those but I've not seen
any evidence that that's real Reiki I
believe to be pseudoscience and
completely not not backed by any actual
science the idea of Reiki sort of
depends on the same concept of a soul
right I mean it's funny because a lot of
Reiki practitioners and and clients of
Reiki practitioners are non-religious
but the concept of Reiki sort of depends
on an invisible energy that has
knowledge of a knowledge in and of
itself because the Reiki practitioner
doesn't even have to know exactly what
the ailment is of the client in order to
be able to sort of move energy around to
solve it I mean listen if you want to
demonstrate that that's real under
controlled conditions let's do it but
I'd it's not something I I believe is
real as of right now what do they do
they have the client lie down or
something and then they move their hands
over them with
yeah they're close to move around the
energy and help them apparently now
there is contact Reiki but it at least
started as non-contact also a lot of
Reiki fans believe it's an ancient art
it was developed I believe in the 1920s
by some guy say there's really nothing
nothing super ancient about it now
acupuncture is an interesting one
acupuncture can have some positive
results even relative to a total placebo
and total placebo is relevant here but
it appears to be that it's the release
of endorphins caused by the insertion of
needles right so for example something
like headaches of unknown origin which
could likely be stress-related or
whatever it appears as though the
placebo effect of the needles combined
with the endorphin release of stabbing
someone with with small needles yeah
could actually improve headaches but the
question to really test this what you
have to look at is one the efficacy of
the real acupuncture implementation
versus a fake one meaning one where
needles are inserted in random locations
to see if you get the same result if the
results are very very similar that would
suggest that it's sort of the endorphin
element and also you've also got to
account for regression to the mean or
spontaneous remission the fact that some
of the conditions people go to
acupuncturists for our conditions that
would resolve on their own with no
treatment whatsoever there has not been
evidence that I've seen that shows above
and beyond return to the regression to
the mean and endorphin release that
acupuncture is really a real thing well
you're relaxing the muscles aren't you
so I could see how they could help with
pain levels but I don't see how that
would extend to like solving a headache
or you know any of anything going on
with like an inner organ I just don't
see yeah I mean that jump inner organ
stuff there's no evidence whatsoever
there acupuncture can solve I don't know
that a cube I don't know that stabbing
that inserting needles relaxes muscles I
think that it's possibly the environment
of lay down and we'll put music on in
the background and at all that might be
actually if there's any relaxation going
on what what does it which is why
acupuncture is very very placebo
connected
Rolla G no I don't believe that the
location of the planets determines our
future nor do I believe that it
determines our personality so no I don't
believe in that telekinesis telekinesis
I'm actually open to the ability at some
point of humans to harness potential
energy to move objects but I've not so
far seen that it's something that we can
do so for right now I don't believe that
it's a real thing ghosts no I don't
believe in ghosts I don't believe there
is a thing known as the soul I've not
seen any evidence of that lucky and
unlucky numbers no I think that there is
something called ODS and I think that
people tend to remember their successes
and forget their failures so there could
be the perception of what's called a
lucky or an unlucky number but quite
frankly the idea that we've become so
superstitious about that that many
buildings don't have a 13th floor I find
weird I find it I find it weird ability
to communicate with the dead nope I've
not seen any evidence that that's
something we can do
numerology I don't really know that much
about numerology I know that Herman Cain
I think had some kind of 666 numerology
thing going on or maybe I'm
misremembering that but no I mean
generally speaking the idea that there
is sort of a meaning we can ascribe to
numbers beyond just their numerical
value I don't believe in and tarot card
reading I mean just absolutely not so I
guess I mean the person's giving given
me a list of stuff that I just have not
seen evidence for so I sound kind of
like a curmudgeon yelling get off my
lawn I don't believe in any of this
stuff but I'm open to having my mind
changed about all of it in other words I
am not definitively saying all of this
stuff is bogus what I'm saying is I've
not seen any evidence so far that it's
real she's listed like 12 things they're
12 different pseudo-sciences yeah but I
could think of even a few more like
exorcisms or chiropractic medicine or
reflexology like there is so many so
many scams out there yeah well good
thing that their list wasn't uh wasn't
even longer because then it would have
taken me even longer to discuss it so
there it is I don't believe in any of
those things hate to break it to you